this is uh blombos cave it's on the
coast of south africa
it's been the location of a bunch of
really exciting archaeological finds
over the years
some of the first ornamental beads one
of the first drawings the human beings
ever made
between 10 and 20 meters down about 100
000 years old the archaeologists who
work that cave found something
remarkable these are abalone shells and
the one on the right you can see a
little rock down at the bottom
and it's sort of molded to the shape of
the inner surface than the nacreous
substance on the inside of the shell and
you'll see also some reddish color there
that's ochre
and iron oxide these are tools for
grinding that ochre down
for mixing it with they found samples of
what's called trabecular bone like you'd
find in the spine it's sort of
fat and marrow and cartilage porous and
gooey these tools to mix all that
together and make a pigment to turn
ochre into a paint
it's the oldest known example of human
beings taking a natural material and
turning into colored stuff they can use
the archaeologists who found them led by
a researcher named christopher
henchelwood
called these toolkits blombos was a
workshop
for making color technology but by the
time you have people painting
for example the insides of the caves at
lisco in the south of france tens of
thousands of years after what was going
on blombos
you have a pretty wide palette now this
isn't obviously enough of a gamut
to depict the entire natural world but
there's a lot of color there you've got
the ochres there's some coppery stuff
for green
the blacks are magnesium and carbon like
soot that's easy because you've got
fires
and sometimes you'll have something
almost always calcium carbonate based
for white and it's enough to make some
really striking image like these these
are from
the simulated lisco cave that the french
built just outside the real cave but you
can also ask
could the people who painted it also
have had other pigments
and the answer is yes maybe they had a
blue made from flowers or something
we know because they were humans that
they saw color like we do